yes we just had the news that add the
vibe is going to be starting pre-orders
in sometime in April apparently so you
can start pre ordering on februari 29th
it'll start shipping in April okay so 29
that's less like a week ago yeah yeah na
month and and then people will start
getting their systems in April so like
that's right around the corner is
happening yeah but they do need to pony
up eight hundred dollars yes for the
package but let's talk about the value
there yes the oculus rift headset is 600
if i'm correct 600 i'm with that you got
the xbox one pod which almost feels
superfluous in a weird way like i feel
like the people who'd be buying that
might already have gosh but yeah
probably in the headset right and that's
yes with the vibe you get the headset to
their their controllers which our new
brand new built for VR they really do
make those experiences feel distinct and
special and you get the cameras that use
for positional tracking which are like
this like four little do here lighthouse
sensors yeah and all those combined just
make like a really good experience for
VR that oculus is like close to hitting
yeah just not there yet because you
can't you can walk around a small amount
of space with the oculus rift on but you
can't do the full room experience and
they don't have the tech that HTC has
put into their headset either that will
detect when something's in front of you
and give you sort of like a ghostly
image of it so you don't bump into it
yeah but also they're not taking you out
of the game it's just like a subtle
nudge liked by the way there's a wall
there so it doesn't break immersion
either is this like you know obviously
people are saying oh my God we're so
used to spending you know four hundred
dollars for a console or five hundred
dollars for a console and you know maybe
below pcs obviously cost more a lot more
and do you think people are disappointed
at this price point are we are we now at
the stage where the like sort of the
internet community is the gaming
community is kind of figured out that ok
actually VR is going to cost this much
money no matter what I kind of look at
it this way right like whenever a GPU
manufacturer announces their best card
you know it costs what's similar to what
people are going to be paying for these
headsets and frankly if you were to take
V are below the high-end experience
right now you would have something that
is not really desirable so yes it's the
only option but it's a reasonable option
when you consider the sort of the
envelope that exists for this technology
right now you don't want to be at the
bottom you want to be at the top right
ok
I mean that's that's why I don't feel
too bad about it also it's these are the
first headsets that are hitting the
market that are offering something that
is better than just a base level
experience so you can say you used VR
they're offering things that allow you
to actually engage with games in a way
that does feel different and does feel
really good yeah in fact let's just talk
about the games we're here gamespot
let's talk about video game I feel like
when we talk about your half the time
it's always about tech demos I mean
yesterday they really start tech demo
thing on over steam as well we can
people have been actually data mining
that for some really interesting half
life 3 stuff did you see any of that I
saw so yeah yeah just like a headcrab
reference here hl3 they're like okay
well how about a half I figured some
sort of quest system you gotta do some
people at Valverde's doing any of that
think so just like Jesus messing with
this point or even just joke with each
other internally a good one Steve yeah
seems good there hl3 actually stands for
like hollow lamp yeah yeah I don't know
exactly right virgin half life 3 asides
I we were up there you played 12 games
in a row yes this was just a couple
weeks ago steam so valve hosted it with
the steam vr showcase which was
basically here are 12 games that are all
coming out this year coming to HTC vive
right so everything I played is going to
be out at some point within the next
like six to eight months most likely
cool um yeah and what was cool that it
is as you mentioned you know previously
we've seen a lot of tech demos but what
I was playing up in Seattle we're
actually games like games that I could
see myself sitting down and playing my
son what's this guy that it's raw data
oh that is raw data that one actually
play a little more recently that's also
a five game it's sort of a combination
like tower defense / like standing like
gun shooter okay you're basically
waiting for a computer to like download
some stuff for you and you have to
defend the computer sense from robot
assassins we were trying to stop you so
you're basically your motion controllers
your guns and you can get a bow or
shotgun I like the sword situation here
actually in fact you there's a couple of
games you're playing guys he like tilt
brush budget cuts job simulator how many
of these games are games are we were
standing in one position and quite I
mean definitely a few what was
interesting though is that they all did
something really different i mean of the
12 games that i thought i wouldn't on
Seattle each one was very
I mean they were all very different and
they were almost all different genres
there were a couple shooters but other
than that it was it was pretty pretty
interesting I mean there was a mini golf
game there was like a a couple sort of
puzzle games that approach puzzles in
different ways a couple shooter is a
stealth game you know a top-down god
mode game just a bunch of different
stuff and and like I said it was all
stuff that I could actually see myself
playing like they were real games not
just tech demos which was what was so
exciting about her stuff I could
anticipate and like want to play I guess
last question this coming away from the
game stuff is that there was a mobile
world congress that goes on in barcelona
at the moment and was that where
zuckerberg was on stage with ya samsung
was doing their press conference and
they gave everyone in the audience the
gear VR headset which is the thing that
you can take one of your various samsung
phones and dock into it and get pretty
good VR one of my samsung phones yeah
okay what i put in well i want as many
yeah i mean i know you all have a few
right i mean at e3 prom yeah and there
is this image that was sort of like
we've hit this point in VR now we're all
our worst fears come true where you're
in a VR headset and all of a sudden Mark
Zuckerberg is walking around with a
goofy smile on a tight t-shirt yes my
army yeah it's like the tweeter that
sounds like a black mirror season three
yeah yeah that's me miss yes but very
creepy right after the podcast years I'm
sure every time Zukerberg VRE oh look at
that job okay yeah but I are at least
with the HTC vive sort of coming back to
it are they looking I think you know it
sort of talked about getting into that
weird space of oh this is also like a
communication machine which is very much
like what I feel I experience with the
oculus right touch demo and with the
reason my facebook bought it right I
don't think I think it's a good reason
part of the reason why they bought it I
don't think we're gonna see like really
dedicated first party social apps like
the way we imagined now I think it's
going to be sort of a slow build up to
something that is like a really
concerted focused effort on like this is
the social platform for VR so if
anything I don't think you're going to
see valve do too much with it maybe
they'll integrate steam in a way they
are integrating sort of local social
stuff where you can like get phone calls
in the vibe headset where I is which is
a good thing
but yeah I don't see anyone any one
company really going all in on social
stuff right now because that's the first
way to like trigger fears that people
are already expressing before these
things are even out right that's somehow
this is going to like remove them from
reality like bubble I think people need
to get way more comfortable with this
technology before they're willing to
like feel comfortable interfacing on a
regular basis but the headset on yeah
but it does work really well as you saw
at Gamescom yeah the oculus touch thing
that was the one that turned me into oh
yeah this [ __ ] is incredible exactly
yeah I'm just hard to yeah it's an
uphill battle trying to explain that
people who have never tried it because
it's like you can't communicate the
sensation it's like holding a wiimote I
thought [ __ ] like the dorkiest piece of
[ __ ] in the world and I remember like
playing it in in like a day had like a
wee station it was actually in like a
supermarket in Birmingham in the North
videos like that old soup I know right
yeah both the bullring it's a self and I
was there and I literally had to go
tennis it was like oh my gosh yeah so I
guess maybe this'll help people actually
one question here the last one that's
and will actually give it to josh shaw
who's inside helping direct the show I
he says I can't wear a VR headset for
and maybe for over maybe an hour before
feeling bad you played games for like a
whole day what was that like yeah so
this is the schedule for the event that
I attended was it was six hours and I
played games in 15 minute bursts for
like a cumulative total of three hours
of play time and so just playing 15
minutes and taking headset off I was
fine the only motion sickness I ever
experienced was playing not naughty
Valkyrie which other one um the other
space so elite dangerous elite dangerous
thank you yeah and that was only because
like I was driving a buggy around like a
low gravity planet like I'm flipping off
dunes and stuff so I was doing it to
myself um so I was fine i just find it
every time i took the headset off it was
more and more difficult to react llamate
to reality like after having so many
times taken headset off and on I kind of
had to actually consciously remind
myself by then like okay headsets off
back in the real world so I mean it's it
can be a little exhausting but I think
that you know the more people use the
more they'll get used to it and honestly
I think I think it'll be fine I didn't
have too much trouble with it but then
again I'm not generally prone to motion
sick to something like that I didn't
find it uncomfortable or anything I was
equally uncomfortable I wonder if that's
a thing where people are like
I don't know spin eight hundred dollars
just in case like I don't know if it's
gonna make me sick at home I'm really
like the re-emergence of like cyber
cafes you can just go and like try this
for a while right like it you know
talking about but just noise ice all
right you're gonna see it in any
airplanes I think yeah that's not too
far off especially in first class but
yeah well I think give it five years
you're gonna start seeing like maybe if
not that like you know you're seeing
like a lot of smart devices and airports
now like at little tables or people are
waiting granted hygiene is a problem but
yeah I mean you could see VR headsets
and scenarios like that as well yes I
remember it was a Teresa derringer who
was created the cannon brawl whose
artists like and they're making they
made a great view our game as well Kevin
it's called bizarre and she has a
problem flying she's like deathly afraid
of flying and she basically went on a
cross America trip and used her I guess
it was the Samsung VR she used or
Samsung gear called the gear VR sorry
and it's like completely mitigated her
her sickness or her like her anxiety so
yeah it's where it's gonna be
interesting to see where this stuff ends
up thank you both for coming in and
definitely better virtual reality let us
know in the chat if your instant picking
up an HTC or an oculus which one spin
that extra 200 bones or whatever it is
for the extrasensory let us know in the
chat and the comments below
you